Play the one case that everybody has
held,
the speculator and people have watched
the process and operation has been the
Floyd Landis case,
the cyclist where the two different
approaches for detecting testosterone
abuse suggested that an abuse occurred.
They two tasks are totally different
approaches.
Both came up with the same result.
He's challenged that and there's one of
the challenges actually the challenge is
work up the chain of command if you
will.
And I went to the United States Anti
Doping Agency and uh,
the,
the tribunals that looked at that
particular case of experts,
uh,
concluded that there was a doping
violation.
And I believe he's taking this to the
Court of Arbitration and Sport,
which is the last stop.
Uh,
but it was a interesting,
uh,
experience for the,
because people watched how complicated
this all is.
And I,
that's probably at the bottom line of
what I want to say here is how
complicated and sophisticated this all
is.
This is,
uh,
this is not just taking a pill.
Uh,
the science is very demanding.
the adjudication process is very
demanding.
Uh,
there's a lot of stake here.
and the only way it seems to me this was
able to be dealt with.
It's still institutionalized the whole
process.
And that's really how water was born,
whether it was the laboratories,
the collection of specimens,
the handing out of sanctions is
developing the list,
the concept of therapeutic use
exemptions,
which we should talk about.
Uh,
there are so many different elements to
this,
uh,
that,
soundbite critiques of doping really
don't do justice to the evolution of the
end of doping movement over the last
eight or nine
[inaudible].